you're not the only one in Hollywood who
gives relationship advice we have had on
our show several times someone come on
the program and give relationship advice
and his name is Punxsutawney dr. Phil
let's get Punxsutawney dr. Phil out here
now if you don't mind Punxsutawney dr.
Phil do you have any advice for our
studio audience tonight
you're young you're beautiful you're
intelligent you're vibrant you have all
of these things and you have to decide
that you are lovable you have to decide
that you are acceptable okay now dr.
Phil I want to know what did you think
of that advice well I think that is a
cheap crappy puppet and I think he's
ripping me off that's what I think
whipping you on he's ripping me off dr.
Phil does that puppet make you angry it
makes me very angry to tell you the
truth I don't mind telling you I will
help you with your anger I will offer to
get you professional help with those
issues what do I think yeah I'm not
taking advice from a stupid groundhog
puppet that's what I think what you need
to do is hire you a hooker wear more
jewelry wear tight short dresses and
just look like Beyonce
that is stupid advice I am NOT going to
do that then I will kill you
what did you say to me I will kill you
you want to dance muster
[Applause]
we'll see you next time please
Oh dr. Phil you're an amazing sport
actor Phil here you carried a bowie
knife has a bowie knife I know that I'm
from Texas dr. Phil airs weekdays at
check your local listings always real
I'm talking to you you're good man
[Applause]
you